yeah but I think like I I have a group
of friends right and when I walk into
the room with a group of friends I know
immediately who's going to get the most
attention from the guys it's it's not me
right I have like a friend who's like
very very attractive and I know when I
walk into a room with her like the guys
talk to her first because like girls you
can kind of just feel it but I almost
wonder when I hear like and I hear this
from girls a lot like I'm a 10 I'm a 10
I'm a 10. if that's not like rooted in
reality because attractiveness like
there's numbers behind it whether it's
just your results in the world or your
dating app data or the like the type of
guys you can get